hi I'm Erik Bosse and the new venom
movie starring Tom Hardy has a new
teaser trailer that's pretty much all
teased and not much trail yeah we still
don't get to see Eddie Brock in his true
venom form unless you count that spooky
spooky face at the end looking closely
there are definitely a few interesting
shots worth noting with clues that could
point to this being an actual movie and
not a fan-made trailer so let's go
through this frame by frame and find out
whatever beans this teaser is willing to
spill beyond the fact that Tom Hardy's
in this movie Bob's spoiler warning if
that's even possible and let's take a
look
[Music]
everyone's got this thing maybe it's a
breakup
yes okay the first half of this trailer
shows us some super exciting shots of
Eddie Brock lying in a hospital MRI
machine but look closely in that lab and
you can see an x-ray showing Brock's
spine now in the classic origin story
for venom and extraterrestrial symbian
attached itself to spider-man giving him
a cool shape-shifting black suit but
screwing with the sense of identity so
he used the sonic waves from a bell
tower to detach it where then latched on
to Peter Parker's rival Daily Bugle
reporter Eddie Brock he may remember
this version of events playing out in
spider-man 3 with Topher Grace as Eddie
Brock but there have been various
versions of venom over the years in the
comics one has Eddie Brock getting a
cancer and using the symbiote to cure
himself and one of the later hosts was
Flash Thompson from Peter Parker's high
school days his army service left him as
an amputee and the Sydney it attached to
him healing him and turning them into
agent venom who could actually control
the symbiote and then he later became
anti-venom I'm bringing all this up
because maybe this movie is using some
element of this kind of medical
backstory with maybe this movie Eddie
Brock separating some spinal injury and
using the symbiote to heal himself but
when it comes to comic influences notice
how this story is set in San Francisco
not New York where the venom
spider-man's stories are normally set
this is because director Ruben Fleischer
has said he's pulling a lot from the
venom lethal protector comic series the
first time Eddie Brock was the main
character slash hero of this story
instead of a villain - spider-man and
that story lyin Eddie Brock reaches a
sort of truce with spider-man and moves
to San Francisco where he runs into an
organization called the light foundation
and five offspring symbiotes actually a
first-look photo that was released a
little while back confirmed this with
Eddie Brock holding open a reporter's
notebook where if you zoomed in flipped
it and reversed it you can see the words
light Foundation hmm yeah I'll talk
about these guys later then we see
Michelle Williams character it sounds
like she's playing and weighing in the
comics she's a lawyer who has a kind of
toxic relationship with Eddie actually
the later point she bonds with the
symbiote to to become she venom because
in comics all characters eventually
become super and before I move on
there's a shot of Eddie Brock sneaking
into the lab
late at night maybe his investigation of
the light foundation leads to some
snooping during which this Symbian
patches onto him and that will kind of
be his origin and we get some clues on
to what could trigger this investigation
in the next section
[Music]
an accident
whatever it is you used to be one thing
now you're something else okay here we
get some indications of the mystery that
Eddie Brock is investigating what looks
like some burned remains under a tarp my
guess is that they belong to the victims
of this crash site in the woods this
looks more like some space craft maybe
this was the source of the alien
symbiote traces of which might have
survived on these remains and then
attach themselves to Eddie Brock and
although this venom trailer is pretty
much devoid of venom I think the
showcase element is Tom Hardy his facial
acting here in the MRI is pretty great
the sudden awakening as he faintly
realizes a venomous presence inside of
him it's the kind of face I make when I
wake up feeling like that spider has
crawled in my ear not just an irrational
fear guys it's gonna happen let's go
we all have our own problems
our own issues okay here we get our one
look at the Rossum biet in this trailer
encapsulated inside this container bond
over by Riz Ahmed characters it's not
confirmed but he may be playing Carleton
Drake the head of that light foundation
group I talked about earlier so in the
comics the light foundation is a
survivalist society that has prepared
for the nuclear holocaust and the Utopia
that they would want to build thereafter
now they get their hands on the symbiote
and use it to form five offshoot
symbiote incarnations named agony fades
riot Lasher and scream in the lethal
protector series spider-man and venom
team up to fight these five and I may be
reading into things here but notice how
there are conveniently five scientists
standing behind
Riz Ahmed here saying these could be the
host bodies of those five symbionts if
this movie decides to go that way and I
would say that would leave Riz Ahmed as
a possibility for carnage I was
announced last year that carnage would
be in this movie
we just don't know who's playing him yet
in the comics carnage is Origen was the
convict named Cletus Kasady
a truly disturbed psychopath who at one
point shared a prison cell with Eddie
Brock who's simply had produced an
asexual offspring that latched on to
Cassidy who later broke out and became
carnage one of the most shockingly
violent villains in all of Marvel Comics
if this movie revises that origin story
I would just hope whichever character
hosts the carnage symbiote is already a
deranged person because that more
extreme state is really the main thing
that separates carnage from venomous
characters and with some generic car
crash footage and Tom Hardy jogging in
the woods we move on to the final part
of this trail
demons
so here we get one of the most
interesting shots of this trailer some
corporate setting where suddenly the
employees and computer monitors are
swept away as if hit by a telekinetic
shock wave of some time now the editing
sequence suggests that Eddie Brock's
reach in the previous shot caused this
but I'm guessing that's from a
completely different scene also
telekinesis or a force push whatever
this is isn't really part of Venom's
powers or the abilities of any of the
symbiotes that we've seen the comments
before however look closely again at
this shot the computers and phones and
desk lights get blown away along with
the employees but the chairs the
wireless keyboards mouse pads and
post-it notes are still standing so why
is some of this stuff getting pushed but
not all of it it's a stretch but I'm
thinking this could be connected to
carnage in the comic series carnage
unleashed carnage sends his symbiote
through computers and communication
lines actually kills an Internet hater
who tries to claim that he's just a hoax
he drills into the guy through a
computer screen yes it's one of the
goofier ways carnage kills people in the
comics no it's always kind of weird when
superheroes can just become part of
computers it's not how the internet
works it's not plumbing I'm just saying
that carnage infecting this office is
hardwired might explain why only really
the communication technology and the
guys wearing these phone headsets are
getting swept away here while the other
furniture isn't and then finally there's
Eddie Brock back in that MRI as a
symbiote gets activated and starts to
take over and he doesn't like it I'm not
sure why the MRI is triggering this it
grates it scans with electromagnetism
and radio it's not sonic ones but if you
look closely you can see the black women
sneaking up the veins in his neck this
is interesting because in past
depictions of this transformation the
symbiote spreads over Brock's skin
smothering him like an inky sticky
blanket gross whereas here venom infects
his bloodstream very much like snake
venom which in some ways is a more
accurate reflection of this inside out
way the symbiote haunts his mind and
personality actually now that I'm
thinking about this let's listen again
to the voice from Tom Hardy that we've
been hearing throughout this trailer you
used to be
now you're something else I'm wondering
if this isn't the voice of Eddie Brock
but the manifestation of Venom's voice
inside Eddie's mind everyone's got their
thing their own demons yeah it could be
a taught from the Cepheid as he explains
it OC nature of his psychological and
the station you can always count on Tom
Hardy for bringing a really weird voice
to a superior movie can't you it would
be extremely painful you're a big guy
for you question for you guys do you
want to see Peter Parker cameo in venom
there were some rumors that Tom Holland
was spotted on the venom set but I don't
know if the family friendly neighborhood
spider-man belongs in this story comment
with your thoughts down below or tweet
me directly Eddie a boss and follow new
rock stars on Twitter at new rock stars
for updates on her videos and of course
subscribe to new rock stars for
breakdowns of all the big trailers to
drop this week Deadpool Avengers
infinity Wars so Louis Star Wars stories
and if you really like this channel want
to help us grow you can contribute to us
on patreon big thanks to all of our
donors especially Alan Fleming thanks
for watching guys bye